hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well one of the most
revolutionary conclusions of Plato's
dialogues as a whole and this dialogue
especially is that not only do poets or
that is artistic creators not know what
they're doing only do what they do on
the basis of some sort of irrational
enthusiasm not possess knowledge about
the myriad things that they actually
talk about or depict but even their
interpreters in this case the Greek raps
ODEs but we might think of those who
enact those sorts of things you know for
example if there's a play that we're
putting on the director the actors all
those who are putting on the play none
of them actually know the subject
matters that they're working with unless
they happen to be experts totally
independent of their function as artists
as poets or interpreters now for the
ancient Greeks that would have been
extraordinarily disruptive
extraordinarily revolutionary because
they did look to Homer and Hesiod and
many other poets for wisdom for
understanding about how to do things
they didn't have textbooks for
everything
some textbooks were being written you
know for cooking for rhetoric for
medicine for these sorts of things
around the time that Plato himself
teaching and talking but there were all
these well-developed we could call them
skill sets bodies of knowledge and those
played an important role in things like
The Odyssey and the Iliad so you notice
I've got this big schema here in the
Odyssey and in the Iliad because they're
talking about Homer here who I haven't
happens to be a specialist in you know
there's issues of divination divination
is the is a religious function trying to
figure out what the will of the gods is
and that's something that comes up at
many points in the Odyssey in the Iliad
they're trying to figure out what are
the gods actually want from us what kind
of sacrifices what can prayers what kind
of rituals do we need to do in order to
appease them in order to get them on our
side will our ventures be successful or
fail all those sorts of things
Chariot Racing you might say well that's
not a very important thing well it was
for the ancient Greece you know
particularly for the ancient like you
know akkyun nobility
they were still into chariots at that
time and we could think of all sorts of
other things for us it wouldn't be
Chariot Racing would probably be
automobile driving you know equally
important fishing we might put in there
agriculture we might put in there all
sorts of other things that produce and
there's a lot of discussion of strategy
or military matters and Homer ties all
of these together in these massive
tapestries which involve a whole bunch
of characters
there's plot lines there's speeches and
thoughts that are given by these
characters holder is really in many
respects if you've read The Odyssey or
the Iliad
actually like given us the time and
attention it deserves an artistic genius
and the ancient Greeks on it and don't
bother to put comments saying Homer was
you know just the last of a whole bunch
of bards and there's a whole bunch of
productions that led up to it yeah we
know that the scholars have have told us
that but Homer doesn't want to brought
all these things together and for the
ancient Greeks they identified it with
with him so the idea here is that Homer
is really a brilliant guy and you can
learn a lot by by studying him by
reading him by paying attention to these
artistic products you can learn
something about the larger reality that
we inhabit that would mean that the
poet's would possess wisdom or knowledge
of some sort were understanding Socrates
wants to argue and he is arguing this
with ion that no in fact they don't and
one of the questionable starting points
that he's going to get ion to agree to
and probably many readers will agree to
as well is that subject matters are
distinct from each other so there's
military matters and those are something
completely different than fishing there
may be analogy as you can draw between
them but fishing is fishing strategy is
strategy horsemanship is horsemanship
taking care of pigs and raising them for
market a whole different skill set so
the idea is that there are no absolutely
foundational transfer from one area to
another sorts of skills or bodies of
knowledge these are all distinct from
each other and here's where this is
going to lead to problems for the poet
or for the interpreter of the poet Homer
talks about divination now who is
competent to speak about divination
it's the diviner the person who actually
possesses that skillset that competency
that body of knowledge that has been
formed in that discipline so there's
some sort
of expert and Homer is kind of like an
amateur or a dilettante who doesn't
really know that much about it knows
enough about it to say a few things you
know maybe heard something over here and
grabbed a little bit from you know this
person's practice over here that he
observed that he doesn't really know
anything about divination as such Homer
is not a diviner he's a poet
what about chariot racing did Homer race
chariots did he learn how to race
chariots
well Socrates doesn't think that he did
it neither does ion if Homer actually
has anything to contribute as far as
knowledge goes speaking well about
chariot racing he hasn't only in so far
as he was himself a chariot race or were
studied at the end you know the chariot
racing school of Ionia or something like
that but that wasn't the case so he
actually doesn't know anything about it
and can't tell us anything very useful
about it and we can do the same thing
going through all these different sets
of skills you see where this is going
sooner or later the poet is having
stripped away from him any sort of
competency except in say creating poetry
and it turns out that poetry doesn't
communicate knowledge about anything and
the interpreter isn't able to make the
poem speak with knowledge about anything
they're able to get the audience riled
off and interested and have them you
know feel horror and shock and anger and
joy and stuff like that but that's just
playing on people's emotions that's not
actually communicating knowledge to them
they can entertain but it cannot inform
or teach I leave this one for last
strategy why because after all the other
ones have been stripped away ion is
still saying well you know at least
Homer can tell us about this
and Socrates says well that's really
interesting because you know everybody
needs generals so I on
why aren't you in military command right
now and I an says well you know my city
has been conquered by you Athenians so
there's really there's no need for me to
be a general and Socrates says you know
that actually doesn't doesn't hold up
because you know the Athenians hired
this guy and they hired this guy they're
foreigners as a matter of fact if you
actually possess and you can show people
that you possess military knowledge I'll
bet you they'll give you a command and I
am has to say well I guess I don't
actually and Homer doesn't actually have
military science or strategy so what
does this leave us with does the poet
actually know anything it appears that
the poet doesn't this is where and
there's there the other core concept
video that you can look at about the
metaphor of the Rings
if the poet is actually able to
communicate anything that turns out to
be right opinion that is that turns out
to be a belief that is aligned with with
what's true that could you know sort of
imitate these subject matters these
these areas of competence it's only
because the gods have you know spoken
through the poet they've given the poet
some sort of supernatural advantage and
so the poet without even realizing what
he's doing you know communicates that
the rap so does the same thing just like
the iron rings communicating the
magnetic force from the magnet if that's
the case even though then the
implication is that one very important
sector of ancient Greek society where
people were making claims to knowledge
doesn't have any knowledge at all
doesn't communicate any sort of wisdom
it really has nothing of any true value
to say on any of the important topics
ranging from how we ought to comport
ourselves in relation to the gods how we
ought to procure our food how we ought
to drive our vehicles how we ought to
make
to make peace this would be extremely
revolutionary to say and this sort of
looks forward to why in fact the poets
are some of the people who are
prosecuting Socrates at his trial in the
apology
is this the last word that that ought to
be said about this no there's there's
actually something fundamentally wrong
with Socrates assumption that he gets I
on to buy into because I am doesn't know
any better that subject matters the
subject matters that particular art
skills crafts discipline Sciences ver
upon must be totally distinct from each
other and that there can't be any
overlap it may be that poetry at least
for certain poets not not the
run-of-the-mill poets but certain you
know great poets like like Homer or
think about Shakespeare for example
maybe they do in fact have some sort of
knowledge but its knowledge of a
different sort than these disciplinary
types of knowledge that's an open
question that we have to leave at this
time and not try to resolve because
there isn't any resolution for it it's
just something that's being suggested by
the way that this dialogue works out the
bottom line is that for Plato
consistently through through his works
although there are some tensions here
the answer of this of the poet's
possessed knowledge is no